on prime crime charles
hey stop that
a night of partying ends in tragedy you
go straight to the active shooter and
try to neutralize the threat
and an officer's actions in the
spotlight were you trying to seriously
injure or kill the driver of that car i
was trying to stop the threat inside the
vehicle correct
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
what starts as a routine police
encounter ends up becoming a major legal
and national story
it's april 29 2017 and police officers
tyler gross and roy oliver are
responding to a house party in balch
springs texas a suburb of dallas
i stood there made him go right into it
just for a few months just to have some
fun
all these millennials like it's muddy
uh-huh
i ain't gonna hurt you
this is a common call actually i've been
on a bunch of these
you roll up with your partner back up
and you start putting the siren on
that is common to let everyone know hey
we're here we're coming here obviously
we were called here you guys need to
break it up and get gone
where are you in school
all these responsibilities
listen don't do this anymore yeah this
is a one-time thing sir
one of the things you want to do is you
want to talk to
people at the same level that that
person is if you're talking to teenagers
you want to try to relate to them on
their level i thought they did a good
job doing that i didn't think these
officers were hostile or overly
aggressive
while teenage house parties are broken
up constantly across the country
as you're about to see this one doesn't
end like the rest
mr rhodes
i'm officer gross okay
i don't i don't want to see this again
gunshots ring out and officers gross and
oliver run to the street
at that point you have to be thinking in
today's society that we have an active
shooter you at least have to rule that
out the current skill of thought now
is that you go straight to the active
shooter and try to neutralize the threat
try to stop the threat
hey stop that car
stop right there
stop
at the point that officer gross is
trying to stop these cars he's probably
trying to do a couple of things
number one is he's trying to identify
whether or not any of these people was
involved in the shooting
number two and a lot of people don't
think about this you want to make sure
that somebody's not transporting a
victim away sometimes teenagers may
panic
load a gunshot victim in the car and try
to get them to the doctor themselves
yet the driver of one car doesn't follow
officer gross's demands
at the same time officer oliver
retrieves his semi-automatic rifle from
the squad car
when you carry your rifle in the back of
your vehicle
we're trying to carry it and it's called
cruiser ready what that means is you
have your safety on and you don't have
any rounds chambered and you do that so
that there are no accidental discharges
what he did is he took the safety off
and he chambered around in case he
needed to actually use that weapon
copper 28
charles sam seven young 882 charles
sampson young 882 hey stop the
car
stop that car right now
those kids could be scared those kids
would be not involved at all in the
shooting just have alcohol in the car
and trying to get away but you know you
have to assume
the worst that there is potentially a
shooter in this vehicle
and so they're trying to get this
vehicle stopped and then you see the
vehicle not comply and things really
kind of go downhill from there
[Music]
officer oliver opens fire on the moving
car ultimately killing one of the
passengers 15 year old jordan edwards
in the end the investigation would show
the original gunshots came from nearby
gang members firing in the air and that
neither edwards nor anyone in that car
were armed
whenever an officer uses a firearm
at that moment when they pull the
trigger you have to ask what is in the
mind
of that officer at that moment
were the actions of mr oliver reasonable
at that moment
so what was oliver thinking
you all right you have fun
is that possible that's absolutely what
went through his mind i i do think that
that's possible do i also think it's
possible that officer oliver had a
moment of i just fired five
rifle rounds into a vehicle that was
fleeing away
and you know something needs to be said
after a formal review roy oliver would
be fired and later charged with
aggravated assault and murder
the question was was this a crime or
justifiable use of force
when you shoot into a moving car or
attempt to shoot into a moving car
run a very high risk of killing an
innocent bystander
that is a risk
when we return
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
hey stop that car
stop that car right now
[Music]
in april 2017 down in balch springs
texas police attempt to break up a house
party filled with
yeah teenagers is a one-time thing sir
yet when gunshots ring out i expected it
law enforcement desperately tried to
stop any potential suspects from fleeing
the scene but when a car filled with
several people doesn't halt to officer
tyler gross's demands that's when his
partner 37 year old officer roy oliver
opens fire on the car
striking and killing a passenger 15 year
old jordan edwards
[Music]
not only was neither edwards nor anyone
in that car the active shooter that
night but none of those occupants were
armed
so why did oliver feel it necessary to
shoot
you all right that's fine
he's trying to hit you
roy oliver was charged with murder and
aggravated assault for the death of
edwards however securing a conviction
against the former officer and ex-marine
would be anything but simple for
prosecutors
it is rare for an officer to be found
guilty of an on-duty shooting and it was
more rare back then
especially in texas which is a very
pro-law enforcement state they're going
to cut that officer a break
with a nation watching this critical
trial began in august 2018.
five of these shots
all of them
including the first one
were fired after the chevrolet impala
had already cleared past
tyler gross no danger whatsoever none
that fast
that young man right there had to make
that decision
does it have to be a perfect decision
no
does he have to be absolutely right no
it has to be reasonable
in this trial there wasn't a police
interrogation of the defendant for the
jury to watch
instead they had the opportunity to hear
from roy oliver in real time when he
decided to testify
he had to take the stand you have to put
that officer on the stand
to put forward the theory and the
defense that i didn't have time to do
slow motion and look at it in slices of
1 100 of a second
it was a spurred a moment but what was
before me what i knew before and during
this event was reasonable
just from the dispatch it made it sound
like there's
some juveniles stumbling around on the
sidewalks drunk he testified very
professionally he was very knowledgeable
and he's very aware of police policy
procedures tactics so he did very well
with that
then we heard
it sounded like a semi-automatic or
maybe multiple semi-automatics going off
in a very close proximity to where we
were at
oliver explains how the shooting played
out
then i was hearing
stopped the car stopped the car stopped
the
effing car i thought he had
located the shooter or shooters
in that nine seconds i've gone from a
retrieve the rifle made sure was in
proper working order
went from a walk to a run i'm focused on
gross his mannerisms his actions his
voice
the only reason i'm thinking he's going
after his
active shooters he's got them
located we've got to stop the vehicle
it does happen fast i have been involved
in in situations where things happen
very rapidly
and i think the courts give a lot of
deference to the officers for that
reason they realize that this is a tough
job that things do happen quickly
the vehicle
came to a stop
for a slight moment and then
accelerated
it came forward
towards my partner
car is a deadly weapon
use of force basically says unless the
vehicle is coming directly at you and
you have no way to get out of the way
and you're about to be run over then you
are able to use deadly force to stop the
threat
when the vehicle was moving towards my
partner
i almost watched my partner get hit by a
car
trying to stop threats
is oliver correct was the car moving
towards his partner officer gross hey
stop that car
stop that car right now
the body cam footage was not the best
from what i saw the car was not a threat
what i saw was someone inside of a
vehicle trying to get away
it appeared to me
that they were not trying to aim
specifically at him and of course you
never know what's in the mind of the
driver or anyone in the vehicle
perceived as an aggressive threat is a
tricky question and the reason why is
because
it's based on the officer who is there
at the time at the scene
in the situation and what kind of fear
they're in or how much fear that they're
in
up next the jury hears some surprising
testimony from oliver's former partner
i felt that i needed representation
because i was being pushed to be
testify in one way
as it was gaining ground towards him i
had to make a decision this car is about
to hit my partner there are threats
inside the car
and
when lethal force is being presented
towards us i had no other option but to
use lethal force
in 2018 former officer roy oliver is on
trial for murder and aggravated assault
in connection with the shooting of
fifteen-year-old jordan edwards outside
of a house party oliver took the stand
and he testified that after gunfire
erupted in the neighborhood he and his
partner officer tyler gross encountered
a car that refused to stop
oliver believed that the car was about
to run over gross that's when he says he
had no choice but to open fire on the
vehicle ultimately killing edwards who
was a passenger the prosecution though
had some more questions for oliver
do you know all of the uh
problems reasons why you don't shoot
moving cars
all of them other i don't think there's
a way to know all of them
what i observed was when he
was cross-examined they're just little
moments where you can tell he does not
like being challenged at all
you killed an innocent bystander
and you're zeal to kill a driver
i'm not
understanding the zeal
okay in your decision to kill the driver
decision to stop the threat of the
driver was one of them correct
you admit that you killed this hater
he was a perceived threat of that time
perceived threat as a passenger in the
car
we're responding the gunshots to an
active shooter
the car is being told to stop being
detained the passenger was moving making
averted movements
do not know what that drug what that
passenger was trying to do or good
roy oliver's claim that he was justified
using deadly force to protect his
partner got a bit complicated when this
partner took the stand
did you ever fear the fear of your life
no
did you ever shoot that car no did your
field shoot that part no
i didn't feel like the vehicle was
trying to hit me
officer gross was the one that was
closest to the vehicle and if he's not
feeling his life was in danger i'm not
sure why officer oliver feels that it
what i think it's a factor is it a
dispositive factor no
it is possible for one officer to
reasonably perceive another officer in
danger especially if they see something
from a different angle and actually be
justified in firing and another officer
from a different angle or different
perspective not be aware that they're in
danger
it doesn't have to be a unanimous
decision to fire
the prosecution though wasn't finished
they also presented evidence that two
weeks prior to the shooting of edwards
oliver got into a volatile road rage
incident
he uh walked up to the car and
he just asked for um
he already had his gun out he was
already pointed at me
and when he got right here
uh next when i turned to the side all i
could see is the end of the gun in my
face
yeah are you sure about that i'm
positive i can't forget a gun in my face
he was off duty he was not in his
uniform he was with his family and
he ended up pulling his weapon out and
going into police mode while being
rear-ended by a woman and two juveniles
in their vehicle and again that's
another example for me personally of
going this guy escalates everything i've
been a police officer involved in car
accidents before i don't go into police
mode
i don't know that that was relevant at
all does it make it more or less likely
that this officer acted as a reasonable
objective officer in this case
i don't think for two seconds that roy
oliver woke up that morning with the
intention of killing someone at work i
don't think he woke up that morning
blood thirsty wanting to go shoot
someone i think that that is his worst
nightmare and every other officer's
worst nice bear that's not what you want
to get involved in
coming up the jury makes their decision
state of texas versus roy oliver the
verdict form reads as follows we the
jury unanimously
think all court shows are the same we're
talking about your father guilty or not
guilty guilty think again judge caprio
rules with common sense i was having
contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the law on crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
stop the car right now
[Music]
you all right you have fine uh
roy oliver a former balch springs texas
police officer is on trial for the
killing of 15 year old jordan edwards a
teenager he gunned down outside of a
house party
the prosecution argued this was murder
the defense claimed that oliver
exercised justifiable use of deadly
force because oliver believed that the
car containing edwards was about to hit
his partner officer tyler gross
after more than 13 hours of
deliberations the jury returned their
verdict
please rise for the reading of the
verdict
we the jury unanimously find the
defendant guilty of murder as charged in
the indictment
the jury convicted roy oliver of murder
but acquitted him of two counts of
aggravated assault
the verdict was just
you're saying a police officer committed
murder that is a huge deal
no video no justice
that's the theme of this case
if we didn't have videos
officer oliver would have been found not
guilty or
there would have been a hung jury
for officer oliver to react in the
manner that he did
it just was not appropriate it's not
legal it wasn't within department
standards practices policies it wasn't
within the use of force policy that is
pretty much standardized across the
nation
officers like him make it harder for
all the other officers that are out
there doing it right
now it became a question of roy oliver's
sentence a decision once again in the
hands of the jury
before deliberating they heard testimony
from members of both sides of this case
yes i did he he was a great kid there
you know like again everybody always
told me
you all your kids are good in sports but
that's the one that's the one i heard
that a lot
are you asking the jury to consider
all of these
yes
and my son is always asking for dad
we the jury having found the defendant
roy oliver guilty of murder and having
made a negative finding on the special
issue of sudden passion
assess the defendant's punishment and
imprisonment in the institutional
division of the texas department of
criminal justice for a term of 15
years
i thought the sentence of 15 years
was appropriate i know the family of the
victim wanted more
however
i thought that the 15 years
is a significant sentence that is a lot
for an officer but it also shows that
officers even when they are convicted
they do get less time than an average
citizen who may have committed a similar
crime
while roy oliver is eligible for parole
in 2026 he may get a different second
chance
at the time of this taping texas's
highest criminal court has agreed to
hear his case
the court of criminal appeals in texas
is reviewing whether officer oliver's
statements to internal affairs were put
aside you cannot use statements given by
a police officer
in an internal affairs investigation
the court of criminal appeals
is looking into whether somehow those
statements were used directly or
indirectly in that criminal
investigation if that happens you're
going to have a new trial
i think that this case highlights a
couple of things i think it highlights
that we are moving in the right
direction as a country and holding
officers accountable as they should be i
think it highlights the need for
departments to go back
and take a long look at their training
how do we prevent this from happening in
the future
this officer made a bad decision and he
did get trigger happy a kid lost his
life a family lost seeing this kid grow
up get married have kids graduate school
go through life experience those years
with him that's a big deal
this officer was doing what he thought
was right but he was wrong and it had a
bad consequence
whatever ends up happening in the legal
case of roy oliver that in no way
changes the fact that jordan edwards
should be alive today if this story can
serve as a cautionary tale for even just
one police officer in the future then
not only will edwards not have died in
vain but another teenager's life
may be saved
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you